Every few years, a school district is
celebrated for some eye-catching numbers.
It is held up as a national model... and
then, later, the numbers are unmasked
as deceptive. In the early '80s,
Atlanta's test scores showed remarkable gains.
The district's secret sauce? Easier tests.
In the '90s, Houston's test gains
were labeled a "Texas miracle."
A 2000 RAND study found these
scores were "misleading" and "inflated."
In the mid-2000s, Chicago was hailed
as a model for "fixing America's schools."
It turns out that the impressive passage
rates were fueled by lowered standards.
By then, Atlanta was being
celebrated again, and then district
leaders went to jail for cooking test scores.
I could list many more. The big problem?
Everybody leaps to imitate the
miracle of the moment, which distracts
from the hard work of
actually improving schools.
Be wary of "models" which are a mélange of
quick fixes and charismatic leadership.
So, the next time you're told that
district X has it all figured out, look twice.
Do you think test scores are a
reliable measure of how well school
districts are doing? Let us know in our
poll. Also, let us know what other topics
you'd like our scholars to cover in 60
seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.